you said
something that inspired that resonated
with a lot of people when you said
George Bush doesn't care about black
people
I have to say as somebody who cares for
you that yay the artist formerly known
as Kanye West
doesn't care about Jewish people
in the same way you spoke about George
Bush being a politician and not giving a
[ __ ] about the poor people that suffered
after Katrina you're not giving a [ __ ]
about the suffering of the Jewish people
across the world wow why am I not
because you're feeding you're giving
strength motivation we already updated I
gave an apology you said it wasn't good
enough yeah that's right and now you're
telling me no I'm not gonna you don't
need to kiss anyone's dick well yeah
you're asking me the kids to say it was
wrong to say there's no Jewish media
there's no Jewish uh there isn't there's
no control of the media by Jewish
engineer brother if you're an engineer
and you're not holding to the truth
that's not engineering engineering is
not that's not it doesn't that's hate
that's not engineering I'm gonna build a
better record label it's called Sarah
I'm going to respect stereotypes exist
for a reason Engineers don't do
stereotypes stereotypes are dumb they
allow you to channel hate towards the
other you know what the biggest thing is
yeah
with a something of Veteran that was
sitting next to me at Cheesecake Factory
last night
uh he said
you know the the general Justice he
serves for whoever is the president
right and he said what's happening in
politics is
we're forgetting we're on the same side
we're forgetting around this this is
someone is practically now he's a nurse
so he's still you know fighting for
Humanity in a way he went from holding
you know guns in battle to being a a
nurse and uh when people are battling
for their lives and he said we're
forgetting we're on the same side this
is a person that no matter who becomes
president he can still be told to go to
war
and the chaos that's created by the
media
has split the country
in half and what we what us as being so
the engineer opportunity need to do
right now is find the blue water
where do we where are places that we
agree on and I want you to finish
everything hey I'ma let you finish
everything I've said before you want to
express to me get off all I'm yours I'm
your scarecrow today I'm your I'm your
punching bag today for everything I did
and I want you to stand up for all of
the hate that I'm your Al Gore when he
lost the election remember he almost
became a punching bag for the lady that
had voted on him and she just said all
this stuff and he's like I know I agree
with you right but there's nothing you
know that he could do about it with this
it's like things that you're saying I
agree with you you know it's like if you
sit some kids in the um in the
principal's office and I punched
somebody right I took I took my hand
right as
what it really means even Aria Emmanuel
had to say this is a pop icon right and
I went and just punched
an entire people at one time or said
that I was about to I went like this
right and I got blacked out black
mirrored done right and it's like what
were you even gonna do and why did you
go like this
I went like this
because
I I can't even do I would I would look
insane to physically show you
a metaphor a a a physical representation
of my last 20 years
of what I've been through
as a musician as a father and as a black
person with a political opinion a great
man still through the pain does the
right thing and I think the right thing
is to not say that there's Jewish
control of the media that's incorrect
though that's a [ __ ] lie there is and
they did come and Bully me it proved the
point no the reason you don't say it is
because the world is much bigger than
the forgive me the narrow little world
you exist in your impact stretches way
past those little boardroom meetings
over contracts so what should I have
done what should I have done not say
that you should no be a strong man that
doesn't mention that doesn't match a
religion to people and then fight do you
want to win this fight how do we win
call out individual people build that's
one way because they have a big voice
the other voice that I prefer is to
build another uh uh label or supportive
you're controlling my creative narrative
and my because just like how you're
telling me I shouldn't have said that do
you think there were people telling me I
shouldn't have wore a red hat
no you because you asked me what should
I have done you're supposed to be a
scarecrow so I thought I'm gonna beat
the [ __ ] out of the Scarecrow with my
words right you let me yeah it was
consensual the punching bag is about
because scarecrow actually has a
different yes right I'm like punching
bag I can't say a scarecrow yeah but
every single person that I've sat with
from the point when I wore the red hat
till now has done the same thing
sit in the principal's office and don't
do what you're doing we're in the
General's closet right now together and
I'm not the red hat is very different
the red hat is uh you have a set of
beliefs you represent half the country
that has a a hope a vision for the
future of America that's very different
than without any purpose whatsoever
saying Jewish media Jewish control of
the media you said there's there's no
purpose so you're taking away my history
and my reason of what my purpose was
I'm saying awesome also also I'm
speaking my voice vocalizing also yeah
it's God's plan